but you know what kind of just say
something [ __ ] the Yulin Dog it
festival oh that shit's [ __ ] up that's
what that okay wait what dog eating
festival oh you don't know about it I
thought oh yeah dog eating festival
every year right what kind of oh my god
give me back your phone your phone
matter yeah ASSA so basically they don't
just farm dogs they steal people's pets
so let's say like they steal people's
pets from like gated communities - yeah
so like actual breed dude yeah
like your car my dog yeah yeah oh it's
crazy cuz I always thought they just ate
wild dogs so I was like no that's okay
they eat everything and they prized the
dogs differently and what's funny is
about this is that people who actually
defend the Yulin dog eating festival say
that oh this has been a part of our leg
you know a part of a culture for many
years but it hasn't that's a new thing
oh my god and it still goes on and then
when they you know actually cook them
it's terrible I mean that's not that
frightening because they could be any
animal but a lot of these dogs are pet
so people's they have collars right and
they have this like you know mean this
the chain thing whatever and they they
grab them and then they've done mopeds
and they drive them to the festival they
sell them for a hundred bucks or
whatever it is and it's go there there's
there's this but it's not all Chinese
because there are there is like a group
of Chinese people who are really really
against us who go to Yulin every year
and who actually tried to buy the dogs
to save them yeah yeah but they boil
them a lot the way they kill them was
crazy and the dog is still alive and
he's being boiled right and he's gone
I'm not like way supportive
that wasn't the best dog of shootin like
yeah at least at the very I don't know
because bullets cost money boiling
waters free economical yes it is it's
economical you know but it's that thing
has to stop you know I mean and that's
bad on China China in general I think
yeah I mean if the [ __ ] south of the
United States had something like that it
would be a shame on the country I mean
Michael Vick shame on the country you
know that was you know not too long ago
we're just as awful with every other
animal though I mean pigs are
technically more intelligent than dogs
yeah but I mean like dogs are like our
friends right great it selects what
histor dogs are her friends we actually
do more damage to the environment just
by having cows in eating cows yeah I
know but they're so delicious you know
good value I think in Peru they have a
cat eating festival once a year to in
Peru yeah
what's their issue I don't know they
just like at Peruvians but just cats
yeah I'm not quite as against I know but
look at me right now why I mean no
offense cuz I know you have three of
them but I mean I I'm just I don't know
what do you mean you don't know they're
not her friends yeah let me tell you
something right now I mean I don't I
think it's wrong you don't you don't
think it's as wrong by buying a strike
you aim another striker at all she's a
friend of mine okay I'm gonna talk about
it right what the [ __ ] is your problem
okay I let me just say something my
[ __ ] cats are like my family
Wow if some Peruvian [ __ ] ate my cat
that would be wrong no that would be an
issue that would be just as much an
issue to me as if someone ain't my dog
exact okay well then there you go
but it was just like objectively a cat
versus a dog all right your dog and my
cat gunner my cat gunner well uh we're
gonna pick our own right okay fry and
forget that but the thing is is that
they're still okay let's some random dog
okay something might okay
my friend Charlie has a dog right okay
and then my friend cat Katie has a cat
yeah okay
and they're both you get to kill one or
the other cat I [ __ ] swear to god man
what we're what about this
[Music]